I've talked to you before about the
difference between political lies or
politician style lies and just
straight-up pathological type lies
political lies can sort of be hidden
behind blurry statistics and fuzzy math
right so a statement like our plan
decreases the non-discretionary spending
non-military non-defense debt over the
next four and a half year period that
could be sort of true by the letter but
really not reflecting the spirit of a
budget proposal that would be called the
politician lie or Distortion then there
are straight-up pathological provable
lies and Donald Trump for some reason
that I can't really understand dropped
another whopper of an example of one of
those you might remember that Donald
Trump was TIME's Person of the Year last
year for 2016 and Friday Donald Trump
tweeted that he turned down trumps I'm
sorry TIME's Person of the Year award
but he was really specific about how it
happened Trump took to Twitter and said
Time magazine called to say that I was
probably going to be named Man of the
Year like last year but I would have to
agree to an interview and a major photo
shoot I said probably is no good and
took a pass thanks anyway now this is
weird
for a couple different reasons some of
which might be obvious to you and some
not not the least of which is that Time
magazine doesn't do this and the time
Twitter account publicly said that the
Twitter account controlled by Time
magazine said quote the president is
incorrect about how we choose Person of
the Year time does not comment on our
choice until publication which is
December 6th this is a really stupid lie
and Trump seems to have been obsessed
with Person of the Year for a really
long time back in 2012 Donald Trump said
that he that Time magazine lost all
credibility when they didn't include him
in their top 100 list of some kind in
2015 Trump thanked Bill O'Reilly then
Fox News showed The O'Reilly Factor for
their editorial saying that Donald Trump
should have been times Person of the
Year and we also know that Donald Trump
at least at one point was displaying
these fake Person of the Year covers at
some of his properties at some of his
golf clubs and and apparently those may
have since been taken down fake right
fake Time magazine covers were on the
wall at some of Donald Trump's golf
course offices why lie about this what
is the point of lying about something so
trivial and something that is
demonstrably falsifiable I mean this is
a provably false claim and there are
sort of two explanations right one
explanation is this is all part of
Trump's 4d chess that he's playing it's
some kind of brilliant political
strategy so complex that we can't
understand it or it might just be more
evidence that Donald Trump is a
pathological liar with serious
personality disorders I lean towards the
latter on this one and I got a couple of
emails from people saying David
why didn't Time magazine just say Trump
is lying why did they use the language
that they used in the tweet this is
actually something a lot of people in
the audience have asked me more
generally why aren't media outlets more
frequently just straight up saying
Donald Trump is lying as opposed to
saying that he is misstating and this is
actually an interesting thing corporate
media typically avoids using the word
liar because it does have the potential
to create a legal problem for them
because when you're saying someone lied
you're making an implication about
intent there and you might not
necessarily be able to prove that so
saying that something is a misstatement
or not a reflection of reality or
whatever that is more legally ironclad
than saying that someone lied and that's
why I wouldn't expect corporate media to
start using that term particularly when
Trump has been very clear that he wants
to make it easier to sue media outlets
so don't expect the term liar to be used
anytime soon although I'll use it I mean
this is clearly yet another one
Donald Trump's lies